it's the first time a Canadian Prime  Minister speaks to the European  Parliament Justin Trudeau has come to  praise the EU Canada trade deal approved  by Parliament despite protests member  states have 18 months to implement an  anti-terror law which makes it a crime  for foreign fighters or lone Wolf's to  travel and plan isolated attacks eighty  six billion euros that's the amount  allotted to Greece in its third bailout  package up for debate is whether the  country's efforts to slash debt are  enough MEP s want to reform the European  Union as the Treaty of Rome turns 60  this year to tackle crises more  effectively they want a special euro  zone budget  [Music]  it costs European companies roughly five  euros to pump one ton of carbon into the  air and ep's want to bump up the price  to encourage industries to get cleaner  faster  [Music]